hello my name is Juan Celestino yellow
and I am a product manager for
continuous integration continuous
delivery on Google Cloud today we'll be
talking about an exciting new feature
container registry vulnerability
scanning scanning your images for known
vulnerabilities is an important step in
securing your cic the pipeline
vulnerability scanning helps you
identify and address vulnerabilities in
images stored in Google container
registry in turn this enables you to
prioritize patching your images to
address these vulnerabilities determine
whether your environment is affected by
a newly discovered vulnerabilities and
ensure that your images are up-to-date
and protected against the latest threats
first enable the container and analysis
API to use the vulnerability scanner
once enabled it will automatically scan
the container images you have stored in
container registry it uses data from
vulnerability databases for the
supported distributions after an image
is scanned you can see that list of
vulnerabilities found under severity we
are a cloud console the command-line
interface and vulnerability scanners
api's also the vulnerability status of
previously scanned images is
automatically updated when new
vulnerabilities are reported to the
source databases to learn more about a
specific vulnerability in an image click
on it to go to the detailed view using
this information you can find and get a
patch version of the affected container
image if no vulnerabilities are found
for an image it will have a green check
mark with nan found in the
vulnerabilities column you can apply
additional security to your CI CD
process with binary authorization setup
policies to ensure that only container
images that meet your acceptance
criteria can be used in deployments
so to recap vulnerability scanner helps
you secure your CI CD process by
continuously identifying vulnerabilities
in your container images you can use
this information to decide what images
need to be patched
learn more check out documentation for
container registry vulnerability
scanning thanks for watching